today i'm going to share with you the
best ways to know you have the real
extra virgin olive oil now i'm not sure if you saw
my other videos or not on this topic but near 80
of all the olive oil sold is actually fake in
other words it's not the high quality olives
picked and immediately cold pressed it's usually
some diluted olive oil with sometimes canola oil
sometimes you use solvents preservatives all
right the best test to know you have the real
stuff as a little tickle or a cough in the back
of your throat a slight irritation because of a
very specific phytonutrient called allele canthal
allele cancel is a super healthy anti-inflammatory
antioxidant now it's not going to be a
major irritation you're not going to start
coughing a lot it's just going to create
a little bit of a sensation back there
and so you know you have the real deal i mean
for years i had no idea i wasn't consuming the
real extra virgin olive oil and i wasn't
aware that until i actually consumed some
real olive oil and you can really differentiate
the difference real extra virgin olive oil is
fruity it's peppery it's pungent it's bitter
it has a slight grassy taste but it's delicious
versus the fake olive oil which is just bland
doesn't taste like anything now you'd want to
buy extra virgin olive oil in glass containers not
plastic and the real stuff is not less than ten
dollars it's usually between ten and forty dollars
because it costs more to make and it's definitely
worth it i mean if you're buying three liters of
extra virgin olive oil for eighteen dollars it's
not the real stuff and i think um it would also
be worth it to find their website and see what
their story is is there a story about the type of
olive they use do they talk about the process do
they actually reveal where it's made and the real
extra virgin olive oil is pressed it's crushed
and it has a harvest date on the bottle now the
one that i use comes from italy and i've actually
been to the farm where they grow the olives and
i observed the process of making olive oil it's
extremely high quality and i'll put a link down
below if you want to check it out but there's
many different places you can get the real stuff
all right thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next video hey before you go if you're
benefiting from any of my content i would love
to hear about your success story
please share it in the link down below